WE WILL DO ON THE SHOW TONIGHT
IS WHAT WE WILL ONLY SHOW YOU
HERE.
WE HAVE SPENT THE PAST TWO DAYS
WITH THE BORDER PATROL ON THE
GROUND.
AND IN THE AIR.
AND ON THE WATER.
AND YOU WILL BE SHOCKED BY SOME
OF WHAT THE BORDER PATROL SHOWED
US.
HERE IS JUST A LITTLE OF WHAT WE
WERE ABLE TO SEE FOR OURSELVES.
>> MOST OF THE TIME YOU CAN WALK
ACROSS THE RIVER.
BUT AGAIN, THAT IS WHERE IT IS
POTENTIALLY DANGEROUS.
I CAN WALK ON THIS AND SUDDENLY,
REACHES OVER THEIR HEAD.
THE CURRENT IS STRONG AND THEY
GET SWEPT AWAY.
YOU TRY TO HOLD A BABY ABOVE HER
HEAD TO COMAY'S SMALL CHILDREN
ABOVE THEIR HEAD.
YOU WILL SEE THE MOTHER IS
TRYING TO STRUGGLE HERSELF AS
SHE FIGHTS THE CURRENT TO KEEP
THE CHILD ABOVE HEAD AND THEY
BOTH CAN'T MAKE IT.
IF YOU ARE LUCKY YOU GO BACK TO
THEIR LAND AND WAIT FOR HELP.
>> YOU CAN SEE RIGHT ON THE
BANKS, THE TEAM TO SEE THE TRASH
BAGS, AND THOSE TRASH BAGS TO
KEEP THEIR CLOSE DRIVE.
YOU ALSO USE TRASH BAGS WHEN
THEY COME ACROSS.
>> SO THIS IS A LANDING AREA.
WE WENT THAT EASY ACCESS TO THE
COUNTRY.
>> THEY GIVE THEM THAT -- THEY
HAVE TO SLOW DOWN TO GET WATER
AGENTS MORE PROTECTED.
AND WE RESPOND.
SO THESE FOUR UPRIVER.
INTO THE BOAT CAN YOU HAVE TO GO
UP THERE AND RESCUED THEM AS YOU
CAN TELL.
THEY ARE ALL SOAKING WET.
THAT LITTLE TUBE.
THESE TWO WERE RESCUED BY THE
BOAT.
>> FOUR PEOPLE DROWNED THE OTHER
DAY, SAME CIRCUMSTANCES.
>> Laura: HOW DO THEY KNOW
WHERE TO CROSS?
>> [SPEAKING IN NATIVE TONGUE]
>> YOU CAN SEE WE HAVE EVERY
SIDE IMAGINABLE.
DIAPERS, FORMULA, JUICES,
SNACKS, MEALS.
WE PARTNER UP WITH
NONGOVERNMENTAL AGENCIES AND
THEY WILL HELP DONATE SOME
CLOSING TO MY CLOTHING.
A LOT OF THIS HAS BROUGHT HIM BY
THE AGENTS THEMSELVES.
WE ARE PARENTS AND SO MOST
AGENTS HAVE THREE OR FOUR KIDS.
AND THEY OUTGROW AND GIVE THEM
HAND-ME-DOWNS.
>> HERE WE ARE AT EAGLE PASS.
EAGLE PASS SECTOR COME UP
HUNDRED 40 MILES.
AND THIS IS 2 MILES OF THE
400 -- 4 MILES.
WE WILL SHOW YOU WHERE IT IS AND
WHERE IT ALL BEGINS BEHIND US.
AND UP HERE IS WHERE IT ENDS.
THAT IS THE END OF THE DASH >>
HERE WE ARE IN THE DEL RIO
SECTOR OF THE BORDER WITH THE